- [Mark] Country, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
South Central Los Angeles.
- [Mark] South Central. And, you grew up
with both your parents?
- [Country] Nah, my dad sometime.
Cause he was trying important
drugs, but mainly my mom.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
- My childhood was fucked up. Shit.
- [Mark] In what ways?
'Cause I just see my mama getting beat
by different boyfriends.
Cause she doing drugs
and you know, drinking.
You know what I'm saying?
Me, me and my twin sister getting thrown
against the wall as kids
trying to protect her.
You know, I think the worst part
of my childhood where I think...
...got me so angry today.
Mama had this one dude, me and his son,
I ain't gonna say his
name, but me and his son,
he was a year older than me.
I was nine.
So he was ten.
We drinkin' jungle juices,
but we also playin' outside.
We got to go to the bathroom.
So one by one we in and
out the house, but we...
Excuse me...we kids.
He'd get tired of us,
started punching on us.
That didn't work.
We still got to go to the bathroom.
He decide to put a
rubber band on our shit.
To stop us from tryin'
to go to the bathroom.
- [Mark] Who's this, the, the father?
- No, my one of my mama boyfriends.
- [Mark] - Oh, your mom's boyfriend.
- My mom was going to nursing
school. She come back.
I immediately run to the
door. I go tell my mom.
I tried telling my mom, but I'm crying.
She walked me to the bathroom.
I go get him, the little boy.
We both go in the bathroom,
pull my pants down.
I show my mom.
She started crying.
I don't remember how she
got that road van at all.
She got the road van or, and
then it's my friend turn.
This is this dude's
son, his biological son.
You can imagine the pain
we were going through.
This boy cryin' just like me.
This dude don't budge off
the couch for nothing.
Well mom walk us out the bathroom,
I remember her asking him like,
damn you ain't gonna get up?
And mom took her two doors down
where my twin sister was already
at playing with the
little girls over there.
One of my mom's drinking
buddies, ma walk us up in there,
she go back out.
I don't know how long it was,
but I remember my twin
sister run to the door.
Cause she sees my mom.
But we go by the time we get to the doors
the gang of police surrounding my mom.
So the first police, grabbed
my ma, my sister, my twin ran
out and jumped on the police.
I did, they threw us, getting my mom down.
My mom was 4'11.
And these some big-ass...to
me, they were giants.
Cause I was a fuckin' kid.
And they men, like my mom's
4'11, probably weigh a feather.
You know?
They go, they take my mom.
That's when I started hating police.
That's when my authority complex comes in.
Even when I went to prison,
but they took my mom,
you know what I'm saying?
So stabbing him up.
- [Mark] Your mom stabbed him?
- Yeah, she stabbed him 11 times.
- [Mark] He survived?
- Yeah. They kept, they kept
me and my sister together.
They didn't let that lady keep us.
You know, one of my uncles took us
cause he think he finna get some money.
When the money don't come,
he getting punched on for
asking for like simple shit.
You know, fuckin' sugar for the cereal.
My sister got knocked off the damn...
And we go to this one placement.
You know, when you're a
twin, you got certain bonds.
Every time I be laying down,
and she on the girl's side.
I'm on the boys side, I
was just feelin' something.
When I got out the bed,
I kept tryna find her room.
I'll go into one room,
wrong, that girl, go tell.
She get up and go tell.
But when I finally found my sister's room,
like I see this big fat-ass
nigga on top of my sister.
She's nine years old man.
You know, I tried to attack him, whatever.
The other staff hearing
the commotion came.
He swept outta there, I don't
know how he, what he said.
I don't remember all
of that, but we stayed.
We had two more weeks of hell.
- [Mark] Where was this?
- Placement in Gardena.
- [Mark] Is it a foster home?
- It was like, they called it a solar bed.
That's like a, like a
house where you go wait
to go to your foster home.
Like the county jail
before you go to prison.
- [Mark] Yeah, got it.
- We've got next two weeks of hell.
And I'd tell you know,
my sister, I don't know.
I was scared to leave.
We talked about running
away, but it makes sense
to have more heart.
When I see her hop out
the window, I had to go.
My birthday came and me and my twin sister
we start kicking it with,
she snuck over there once.
So she meeting females from
over, you know what I'm saying?
And they're cool.
You know, maybe you go doin'
a little dumb stuff, go
and break a window, you
know what I'm sayin'?
But it was all like good.
So he decide she's my
sister, beat me to the punch.
She got put on the day
before I got put on.
We was yellow kids. You
know, says come back,
she got gang little scratches,
you know a little, a lot.
And I don't care who you was,
you could be the president,
and with all his security,
you do somethin' to my sister,
I found him, I'm comin', man.
You know, she come home. I get
mad, immediately, thirteen.
And I go, ahhh.
And she says, shut up fool.
(mumbles)
Aw, I get mad.
'Cause I felt like you're a
girl. You get put on after me.
But I get put on.
Then I start meetin' my, I saw my friends,
and it's not just all gang, people grow up
that's doin' crime, and doin' all this.
And this same group of
people gonna flock together.
These same people,
they was going through
what I was going through.
I start off with weed to try to escape.
But shit, only thing weed did
was maybe put me to sleep,
but then I'm having nightmares
of what I'm goin' through.
So I didn't want to go to sleep.
So at 14, 15, I'm sniffin' powder.
My sister's still on the weed.
You know what I'm saying?
. But then my friend got killed
and I started smoking shine.
I was hearing a big homie
saying that I'm on shine,
I don't feel nothing.
So it's a grown man
that's bigger than me
ain't feelin' nothin'.
And I want that.
And so I started smoking shine at 14.
That's how he was kinda right.
I didn't think, I didn't have no memories.
I didn't want them.
My memory was fucked up.
I couldn't get past
him, I'm startin' crime.
Us getting thrown on over the wall.
I mean against the wall for
trying to protect my mom.
Aight.
And then my mama almost sold my sister.
You could tell by the gray
sky, she had second thoughts.
Now I was seein' like the
drugs ain't gonna help you.
'Cause you go through what
I went from weed, you know.
I was relaxed and I'm gonna go to sleep.
So I went to the powder,
I could be up, you know.
And the shine just made me
numb, and then the crystal...
You just up.
So if you up, you're going
to be get to doin' shit.
Then you won't be bored
of fixing on something.
Then what's next?
You got to deal with your thoughts.
I don't like my thoughts.
My thoughts made me suicidal, you know.
I try to live off and I use
this word very, very, not loose.
The little friends I do have.
I try to live off them when
I see them happy and yeah...
I can breathe.
But I don't, I be smiling
or whatever, whatever.
But when I had time with
just me, I don't like me.
- [Mark] What you, what
are you using today?
- Crystal, weed, I drank,
E-pills, mollies...
I don't do the heroin rocks.
I don't understand that high.
And I don't like needles and
I knew shit that...Fentanyl.
That's killing people.
So I'm really good on that.
So I didn't stay on the crystal.
'Cause like I say, I don't like me.
I get caught with 20, I think
it was 26 or 27 dime bags
of kush in Shan Judia Park.
I was, my oldest baby mama...
We had two kids, my daughter
Imadi and my daughter Thailyn.
We got into it. We broke up or whatever.
And Imadi want to stay with her mama.
And Thailyn wanted to come with me.
And at the Coronada,
I was paying her room,
weekly for like 17 months.
It just me and my daughter.
Like she going to school, her hair done.
She well spoken.
And her whole family was shocked.
I'm still out here doing my thing.
But at certain time it's daddy time
that that was keeping me
like, like I didn't have...
I could think about them.
Get cracked in the park.
I'm in the County.
Now before I go to let me call
my baby mama, she's in Vegas.
So we, I tell her uncle.
I begged her uncle like, go, go get her.
You gonna stay there
until your mama come back.
I'm in the County, I'm supposed to get out
on August 26, 2015.
I'm a little, uh, where, the worker shit.
So I got access to the phone.
I'm extorting people up in
there, and doin' my thing,
like that's I got phone time.
I called on August 24th to speak to Imadi.
Let me speak to Thailyn, I mean.
Oh she down the street,
playin', you know playin'
with her friend Ebony.
Okay. Well tell her I called.
I'll try to call back whatever.
He didn't tell me that my daughter was
in a hospital with two gunshots
to her face on August 24th.
I called on August 24th
and long story short...
I get out 26.
I call on the 25th.
I'm like, where's she at?
Oh, she went to the store (mumbling).
Aight look, I tell I'm
going to get out to Paul.
I'm gonna come pick her up.
You're gonna go see my PO,
Imma take her shopping,
and we'll work from there.
Oh yeah, she'll like that.
She gonna love that.
When I come, when I come
home home, now I'm going
to look out, just give me,
you know, a day or two,
and imma bless you.
Oh no, this is what families do.
He telling me that bullshit.
But when my daughter is in hospital,
I get out, back down here.
When I, I didn't go to sleep.
As soon as the sun came
up, I go see a home girl.
She let me call.
He like, who is this?
I'm like this Country.
Oh, I was just looking for...
You need to go to Long
Beach Memorial Hospital
to see Thailyn.
She finna check out...click.
I'm like what the fuck? I call back
and he didn't answer, going
straight to voicemail.
Then it ring and ring.
Then he don't answer.
Then start going back voicemail.
I finna slam my home girl's phone.
When she get that, she watching
me now what's going on?
And I tell her what she said.
He's like, my home girl's
like, fuck just go up there.
We go up there, I don't
know I start feelin' weird
before that door open,
I start feelin' weird
because I think he did on some drunk shit.
We get there.
We get to the little booth.
My mouth wouldn't even open.
You know, she grabbed me, you know.
I gave her my daughter's name.
Because I expected her like, no no.
You sure she's here?
Oh yeah. She's in her room.
So I'm waiting on them
to give me my sticker.
So I go on up there.
Then she said I needed an ID
because the police some shit.
That motherfuckin', um,
hospital police and (mumbles)...
like a highway patrol officer
or somethin' get ready
to charge their guns.
Cause I'm finna die right here.
You telling me my child is up in here
and I can't go up there, you know?
But it was this Mexican lady
and that was kind of hard.
Cause I ain't saying I'm racial
but from the street politics
and the prison shit...
I don't like Mexicans.
This lady like, lie, put her
job on the line, all of that.
You know what I'm saying?
And she's like, where's your backpack?
I told you to get your
tag off your backpack.
Keep it on there.
You know?
And he was already up here.
He just don't listen.
I told you to put your tag up there.
Come on boy.
Okay. It's finna go ugly.
I get off the elevator,
I see my baby mama.
I see her granny.
I don't see him at first.
Then mama ran.
Stop hugging me and crying.
I go, I open up that door.
I see my baby's head, wrapped all up man.
These tubes, these tubes everywhere.
It was only a nurse in
there, but she on this side
of the bed, I don't, I don't
know how you get to that bed.
It wasn't nobody else in there
holding my little girl hand.
And um, 17 minutes later, she,
she, she, she, she, she...
she left.
As me being a member of
the street, I understand...
That's what he was supposed to do.
But as that being in mind,
I go without saying now,
that's why I do drugs.
I can't remember the last time
I been sober imma say that.
- [Mark] Ever since your
daughter was killed?
- From jail too.
I don't think I like being sober.
'Cause I have to deal with me.
Yeah. I don't know what
it's like being clean.
I don't want to be clean.
Then I got to deal with me and I'm cool.
Cause both of my kids
would still have been here.
If I was man enough to
get up once a month,
get dressed, go see a
dude with a badge on,
pee in a bottle,
it would probably take an
hour and a half outta my day.
My kids still would have been here.
But I was so caught up in
my bullshit, my addiction.
All of this shit is an addiction.
Gang banging's an addiction.
Shooting dice with the
homeless is an addiction.
The robberies and the dope that I...
that that's that's that's
that shit become you, man.
I don't mind being in a
job that was suit and tie.
I get off work, my tie be off
and I'll be right in the seat.
Or all the homies that's doin'
feelin' like I'm feelin'.
Yeah, that's about it.
- [Mark] So...You told me about
your 14 year old daughter.
You also lost your other child?
- Yeah, my oldest, during this
time, her mama didn't want to
cause I wanted to kill her uncle.
She didn't want to tell
me where he was at.
So I'm tripping on her family members,
caught tailin' her house.
I'm shooting that motherfucker up.
Got my home girl jumping
or jumping family members.
Cause you tell you turn
it in, turn him in.
Then I would have stopped.
But she didn't.
So my daughter, my oldest,
like she got on the bus.
My baby mama, cousin, and her
daughter to Augusta, Georgia.
She called me when she was on the bus.
You're on the bus to where?
I'm going to Augusta, Georgia.
It's done.
And maybe a good year before
she passed, and my granbaby.
She hit me up on Facebook,
you know, we get to talkin'.
And she like daddy, the
reason why I had to leave is
because I was watching
my, I just lost my sister.
I guess y'all forgot about that.
And I watched my daddy
trying to kill my family.
The other side of my family.
I wasn't mad.
I was proud.
She waited till she was
20 to have her baby.
She had a job.
She was doing her, she was doing her shit.
So I wasn't mad. And one day, she comin'.
She come back from work, go
get my grand baby from daycare.
Drunk Mexican I guess was texting,
and crashed into her car.
That's how I lost them.
I started slowin' down on my crystal.
Shit, went right back up.
Now I'm at where I'm at.
- [Mark] This happened in California?
- Nah, she died in Augusta, Georgia.
- [Mark] Augusta, Georgia?
Wow, that's a lot to deal with.
- Shit, plus I had what,
two sisters and I got...
Something's goin' on with my brain.
He says, I'll gotta do some, some surgery.
They say seven and some
change hours on my head.
You're gonna get to fuckin'
with, I'd explain it better.
But basically, one day Imma
wake up to a vegetable.
He told my auntie, Imma
put it into layman's terms.
Just imagine you wake up blank.
So all that is to say, (mumbles)
getting high, doing what I'm doing.
I ain't got no light in
the end of my tunnel.
I don't care.
No, I go on one sometimes I don't care
about getting beat up. I'm ugly already.
Whatchu gonna do, gimme a black eye?
Imma show my black eye.
Well, then you come in my little circle,
which is a dot,
you gonna get what you got comin'.
- [Mark] Alright Country, thank
you so much for talkin' man.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] That's a horrible story.